and so the executive producer of the
film came on board and he's known from
Andy's flip this house and that's
Armando want along monkey Armando
Montelongo I had not met I didn't even
really know about him because Brian
never really spoke to me about him he
kind of said it vaguely initially when
we were packaging this together he said
who I work for this guy it was really
successful in real estate and that that
was about the extent of my knowledge
amando montelongo when I was packaging
this together because Brian had come out
to Hollywood and together we were sort
of taking meetings with a lot of
production houses and studios trying to
sell this story I put a package together
business plan budget all that stuff and
when we went to these meetings it was
very difficult because he are Brian
stutters a little bit and I think a lot
of people thought that he was always
nervous in the meetings and they were
like calm down calm down and he wasn't
nervous he just has a slight stutter
sometimes you know and obviously if he's
nervous it gets worse but so a lot of
the meetings had these hiccups because
they all thought that he was nervous and
and being the director you know or
pursuing the the first-time director of
his project that he wrote that made
investors a little hesitant of like this
guy's not confident
enough to direct and he was he's
extremely confident but he had this one
you know physical trait they kind of
perceived him differently and also there
was the aspect of where every person
that we met with would say well because
in her business plan all the leads that
we had already Walter Perez Jeremy ray
Valdez myself and Fernando Romero
attached so we had them in the business
plan and they're all Latino so when any
investor looked at that business plan
they didn't really see any white faces
familiar faces they just saw a lot of
brown faces and that was another reason
why they were very hesitant because they
were like mmm can't you make one of them
Latino and maybe the other three you
know like leave the girl as latina and
maybe the three guys are all no I'm
Latino and that happened a lot so we
just kept going and it was very
heartbreaking because you know Brian was
out here he has his own family has two
kids and a wife back in San Antonio so
he was apart from them and he was out
here and he kept hearing this you know
constant like change your characters
maybe we need another director because
you don't seem like you're you know
confident enough person to direct this
film so those were the obstacles that we
faced and we just did our best to try
and educate ourselves eventually we went
and met one of the directors that I
worked with on band of brothers and the
mentalist David Nutter and he gave us
some great advice Brian had great
editing skills and he told Brian that
Brian should edit a sizzle trailer of
his film from clips of other movies so
he should take clips of other movies
that are thematic to what he wants
mission park to be
and fortunately for Bryan all the actors
who were attached to the project
Fernanda Walter Jeremy and myself had
work that he could you know extract
scenes from so he pieced this amazing
trailer with us in it and it looks like
the film it was brilliant finally he saw
or Armando saw that Brian was really
putting in the effort to get this
project made and i met with Armando
finally so I think he was like wow this
project and these guys are really
serious so he read the script finally I
think after two years of Brian trying to
get him to read the script I only took
one year her mother took two years to
read the script and he loved it and I
think after that Brian showed him the
trailer that he had made that David
nutter recommended he make and our
mondal thought that we had made the film
already and he felt like what I missed
the boat on this one and he hadn't Brown
was just very clever up making the
trailer and that sort of is what
kick-started Armando into joining the
team and and he's been an amazing
supporter I mean he's our sole investor
one man and we always believed that one
person would come and believe in this
project the way we did and that was
Armando
you